the nominees are Richard Brooks for cat  on the Hot Tin Roof Stanley Kramer for  the Defiant ones Nellie for Gigi  Robert Wise where I want to live Mark  Wilson for the end of the sixth  happiness love you announce the winner  mr. Perkins Gigi  ever since G she was written years ago  by Colette  it's been produced in through the years  and many mediums many versions and many  languages and it has a history of  bringing wonderful things to the lives  of people connected to these productions  I know personally of a great many of  them and I'm sure the great many more  and it's brought wonderful things to the  people s connected to this movie to me  tonight it's about the proudest moment  of my life  and I want to give my deepest gratitude  to you and to Gigi for this great honor